hello
and welcome to a very special live
episode of trigonometry it's great to
have you here
we have a fantastic guest if you're a
first time viewer of the show we have a
very special slogan don't we francis
it is it's honest conversations with
fascinating people
and it does not get any more fascinating
than the guest we have
for you today the last time we spoke to
him the title of that
episode was can we can stop a civil war
uh let's find out if he still thinks so
brett weinstein welcome back to
trigonometry
well thanks for having me it's good to
be here guys yeah can we stop the civil
war that's the question huh
yeah well why don't we just start right
there
yeah i would say um it's still possible
but you know the more times we kick the
can down the road the harder it gets and
that's really
at some level the lesson of
the last several decades this is not a
problem that can be ignored forever
and uh you know it's a bit like quitting
smoking the fact that it's difficult is
not an argument against doing it right
now because it only gets more so
well before we get into the analysis of
everything that happened yesterday and
the bigger picture because it's
something you've been talking for a
while i should just say i forgot to
mention at the top
for everybody watching welcome if you
want to ask a question please send it in
the paypal link there's a
there's a link in the pinned comment or
you can use the super chat function on
youtube
and after we've spoken for about 45-50
minutes here with brett we will get to
those questions for another
30-40 minutes and try and get as many
answers as we can
but brett what happened yesterday in
your analysis rather than looking at the
mind you
mind you shy of it what is the big
picture events that we're seeing unfold
in front of our eyes at the moment
well you know i think we're seeing
physical manifestations
of processes that we're all in some
sense familiar with even if we don't
necessarily understand them we interface
with them
all the time on social media and so
the question is really what is the ideal
place to stand to see this for what it
is
and you know we have a problem
the problem has a lot to do with
something that we typically call echo
chambers
but i think we don't properly understand
that echo chambers come about in a
variety of different ways
some of them automatic you know these
algorithms
have a purpose but they have side
effects and the side effects involve
the divergence of our shared narrative
such that frankly people on one side
stop recognizing people on the other as
as
even humans whose opinion is worth
considering
and when that happens you know you enter
a kind of
fission process that is not dissimilar
to what you would see
in baboons or chimpanzees where one
group just simply decides to part
company with the other and
strikes out on its own and you know
until we address the
the divergence of our narratives i think
we're going to keep seeing variations on
that theme
and isn't part of the problem brett that
you've used the word narrative
is that both left and right however you
want to classify
these two factions have their own
narratives
which a lot of the time really have no
basis in reality
they're just that a narrative and people
don't engage with it they just parrot
these words and these arguments
well that's one part of the problem but
you know you could do a fairly good
taxonomy i would say that you know what
we would loosely call the left and the
right
narrative are both downstream
of a style of thought in which basically
and you know in scientific terms we
might call it verificationism
uh or confirmation bias and so
you have a wide range of facts
in a complex system and you have people
trying to filter it for meaning
but unless they are well schooled in the
dangers
of confirmation bias what they will end
up doing
is either shoehorning things
into a narrative that they already
believe what we might call
overfitting or they will simply
cherry-pick the data so that only those
things that seem to match that narrative
are even processed and when that happens
they become very convinced that they are
seeing
reality when in fact what they are
seeing at best
is a highly biased edit
and part of the problem as well is that
we have these narratives
and that's that's just been exacerbated
by social media
so people can essentially isolate
themselves can't they
and only be exposed to their own
narrative well
even worse than that i mean that's
certainly where this starts is that you
know you follow people
who when they speak it flatters your
worldview rather than challenges it
but then the the media companies the
social media companies exacerbate this
problem
for what are presumably mostly narrow
economic reasons in other words to keep
you on their
site they'll train their algorithm
to either you know enrage you and keep
you engaged or flatter you or some
combination
of the two but then even further down
the road
we get to the point where they start
declaring certain viewpoints
persona non grata and tossing people off
which causes the people who have these
other viewpoints
to gather in an echo chamber
that actually is physically held
elsewhere
and that echo chamber doesn't check in
with the standard
narratives it doesn't face the critique
that it would
if it were intermingled with them and
this is this is just simply a very
dangerous
process and you know if we were to get
wise about it what we would
realize is that all of the variations on
those
on that theme all of the ones that we've
seen and all of the ones that are yet to
be
invented are a danger to
civilization and whatever instinct it is
that causes us to think
another one of these reinforcement
mechanisms
is a good thing we have to get in front
of that and stop doing it
right let's i want to get a little bit
into some of what happened yesterday
because i do think it's important so
uh you as we were talking before we
started the show
we've been criticizing the tactics of
the far left
for the last four years on this show uh
the reason we are in the current studio
is
we got kicked out of our last one for
saying that blm shouldn't be looting and
writing and it's amazing to me
that people now uh there are a lot of
people on the right particularly who are
condoning what happened yesterday
and that level of cognitive dissonance
is mind-boggling to me surely if it's
wrong when
they do it it must be wrong when when
decide that you've
become attached to does it as well how
are people not seeing that
well a good many of them are i've heard
a lot of people
that i respect on the right recognizing
that as as much as there are some
distinctions to be drawn
here the overarching lesson is the same
which is we don't all
get to decide that you know we've had it
and that it's
time to mutiny now the problem i would
say
for the us especially is that because
the us
was born in an insurrection
it is very hard for us to say
insurrection is
simply wrong right because insurrection
is our origin story and
what that means is that we have to have
some
very uh well thought out description
of what the circumstances are that would
have to be
true in order to justify um
fighting back out of patriotism rather
than
a desire to tear the nation down and you
know this is
uh in some sense an asymmetry
i don't think in the end it makes any
difference in this case but
because what you really had is a small
number of ill-informed
people deciding that they had had enough
um and you know we obviously can't have
a civilization in which everybody gets
to decide
uh to do this but um the
the cognitive dissonance really is
again a manifestation of a system in
which
um we because the institutions
and the mechanisms that are supposed to
help us make sense of the world
have i think universally been captured
the official ones at least uh we are
left to
cobble together our own world view and
that
world view can be um postmodern
nonsense as we've seen on the blm
left it can be uh
insubstantial conspiracy hypotheses
elevated to the level of fact as we've
seen
on the q and on right and
um you know what it is is just
uh a low quality mechanism
filling the vacuum left by the capture
of the high quality mechanism
i'm really glad you brought up the point
of america's birth
story the founding story of america
being the revolution against
uh british rule so
in terms of the narratives that would be
on the manga right right now
is what they would say and i personally
don't agree with this but they would say
the election was stolen in a wide-scale
electoral fraud uh as a result of this
they made
a large number of legal cases which
weren't properly investigated they were
dismissed on standing instead of being
looked at on merit
and when that became it became clear
that the legal avenue wasn't going to
happen
they tried to stop uh congress from
certifying it via a few people who were
who were willing to do that and at this
point
these uh this is what they would argue
just a reminder these brave patriots
felt the need to
to storm in and essentially you know
save america from
from leftist tyranny this is what what
they would argue
how do you dissuade someone from that
world view
well i don't know because the abdication
of responsibility
by the major institutions
by journalists by virtually every pillar
of society
set the stage for this so as much as it
is very important to recognize the
responsibility
of confused individuals
they're not confused for nothing and
they're also
i would say americans generally are not
wrong
in detecting that something about our
system
is fundamentally broken right and so
you know the irony is that the
frustration that motivates
the attack on the capital that we saw
yesterday and
the george floyd riots is in some sense
just
a near universal right anybody who's
paying attention and it's not being
richly rewarded by the system as we find
it
has the sense it's rigged it's not
rigged in our favor
and that's a problem and you know
the other irony is that anyone who
attempts to bootstrap
a proper solution gets demonized and in
fact gets
painted as if they are part of one of
these cabals on the fringes
you know and i've i've faced that myself
as we've talked about
before right anybody who tries
uh to you know carve out a stable space
in the middle in which to discuss what's
really going on and what's at stake and
what ought to be unifying us
is portrayed as a partisan or a fool
or or any one of these things i mean as
recently as
a couple weeks ago idw
was declared far right in an academic
paper that
ultimately there was acknowledgment that
this was preposterous but i mean it was
just simply a clear
attack from the uh the truth-seeking
wing of of civilization on the
sense-making
wing and you know no wonder things have
begun to decohere and and bret you said
that the system is broken could you
delve into that a little bit more for
people overseas or people who are as
not as ophe with the american political
system as you might be
sure now it's a little bit subtle um
because what we have is a pervasive
culture of political corruption but the
corruption
is almost entirely legal that is to say
it is very difficult to meet the
american standard
of proof with respect to
violations of the protections we have
against
corruption right so revolving door
politics being one mechanism
uh nepotism you know bribery being
delivered to the kin
and friends of elected officials to keep
their fingerprints off things all of
these mechanisms
exist and in fact they are
loopholes that were carved out and
enlarged
by effectively corporate interests
that we should have expected
to attempt to do their own bidding at
public expense
by uh figuring out how to corrupt the
process and and
what is um hard to appreciate
is just the degree to which this
actually governs policy
in effect what we have is a political
apparatus that serves the public
interest only incidentally that is to
say
um you know it is there are certain
things on which
the public well-being aligns with
special interests and then the public's
bidding will be done to an extent but as
soon as they depart
there's no question whose interests
govern
so that said the system
because it is born in
the explicit recognition of the
importance
of checks and balances and because the
founders
thoroughly understood um the hazards of
the market in principle they couldn't
have understood
the challenges that would be faced in a
technological environment
but they did understand the danger of uh
conflicts of interest our system is
rescuable
but we have to recognize the degree to
which corruption has taken it over
and has caused people to be an
afterthought to policy rather than its
focus
so essentially what you're saying is
that american democracy is in crisis
i mean i think you know that's a very
safe statement we could go along
it's been in crisis for uh almost my
entire life
um uh you know we have a a process it's
confusing because
in some sense our general elections
appear to be more or less fair
whereas our primaries are where um
the uh the dirty deeds are done
and um so
to the extent that the fanfare in
general surrounds the general election
it looks much healthier than it actually
is
um but in any case yes democracy
in the u.s is in serious trouble
the hazard to it is mundane as can be
but it is going to break apart in
spectacular fashion
in uh events like we saw yesterday
and i i suppose the bigger question is
where
america leads the rest of the world
follows i was talking to my venezuelan
cousin last night
and i said to him you know things that
the world's going down the pan when even
the gringos are going insane
so if if america is in crisis
what do you think is going to happen
around the rest of the world and how is
this going to impact every liberal
democracy
well this is another uh i don't want to
say uniquely american defect but it is a
defect that we have
um to a much greater degree than a large
part of the world which is
i think because of the history of the
20th century
and the um to
an unparalleled state of power that the
u.s
went through americans modern americans
tend to see the rest of the world only
dimly we see our own issues
as paramount and everything else is very
remote but
what we don't easily understand is
the role that the u.s has played not
only in
effectively demonstrating a path to a
better
style of governance a style of
governance
that is built on the idea that
governmental legitimacy
is and must be founded in the consent of
the governed
but we don't understand the role we play
in
stabilizing the world and so my sense is
we are going to have an absurd battle in
the u.s
over largely fictional substitutes for a
proper analysis of what has gone wrong
and the result of that is going to be we
are going to sideline
ourselves and leave a vacuum that is
certain to be filled by countries
that are not remotely as committed to
the values that we hold dear therefore
even just a simple analysis of you know
do you like uh equality right we can
fight over
the difference between equality and
equity but if you like the idea of
equality the last thing you want to do
is create a power vacuum that
empowers china and russia right that
would be a terrible
error brad there's some other
things that i wanted to cover in
addition to the main issue which of
course is very important but
as i think we're starting to zone in in
the course of this conversation
uh on on the issue of social media and
their influence i think
uh while francis and i have both been
openly and outwardly critical of what
happened last night and donald trump
in in his role in it i think what he did
and what those protesters did was very
damaging and irresponsible
at the same time it's hard to ignore
the fact that a very in my opinion
dangerous precedent was set last night
when twitter and later facebook
unilaterally decided to suspend
president trump's account on twitter i
don't know how you feel about it we
haven't spoken about it
but in my view the president of a social
media company a big tech company
essentially
cutting the president's pipeline to
people
off from him in the crucial moment in a
very
heated dispute about the outcome of an
election
the precedent that says to me if you
play that movie forward
it does not look good to me what did you
make of it oh i
find it absolutely terrifying i mean no
matter who this person is and what he's
doing
he is the president any reasonable
person should agree to that and the idea
that those
who you know sell pencils and paper
or you know are vendors of electrical
power
or happen to own the conduits through
which
we communicate that those people have
the right to censor
is so absurd on its face
and in fact what we're seeing is really
a variation on another theme where we've
seen these same tech giants behave
incredibly irresponsibly barring people
left and right for whom
there is no argument that they are
jeopardizing uh
anything important in fact people who
are trying to
prevent events like this like you know
the articles of unity account that
twitter
banned it was it was it was
built to prevent this kind of
uh catastrophe and so the idea that
these people
are going to appoint themselves uh to a
position where they get to decide who
gets to speak to whom
and you know even a duly elected
president is unable to communicate
um with the public is uh you know
clearly that's um a good many steps down
the road to hell
and there's an extra step that i and i
again i don't know whether you'd agree
with me on this but
you've got the the us house and senate
now controlled by the democrats
and the presidency so they have complete
control uh there
and my view is it's highly likely that
one of the terrible outcomes that
results from this will be that the the
democratic party the democratic
presidential administration say
well look what happens when you allow
dangerous
speech to be available online look what
happens when
one man can have 70 or 80 million
followers on twitter and spread
fake news or whatever it is might be we
need to crack down
we need to make sure this never happens
again as google
executives were filmed saying in 2016
after trump was elected the first time
and so my fear is that not only have the
big tech companies awaken to the
tremendous power that they now have
they're going to wield it in in
combination with
the democratic establishment now against
people like us but people like you
people like me
people like francis other people trying
to have sensible conversations online
that are actually addressing
some of the underlying issues you talk
about they're gonna come down
on all of us like a ton of bricks aren't
they oh i
i see this coming and you know we've
we've all been talking about it for so
long that yes
what's what's happened now is going to
accelerate it when you know again
there's just going to be no end to the
ironies
what really happened yesterday in some
sense
was that the feeble
response to
blm violence in particular the sustained
attack on federal buildings
here in portland actually set a
precedent
and you know we i've been involved in a
number of discussions with uh
very smart well-informed people offline
about how one compares the attack on
you know a courthouse in federal
courthouse in portland to an attack on
the capital and obviously
an attack attack on the capitol is
a good deal more serious in one regard
but then again
it was a momentary attack whereas what
has happened
in portland was a sustained attack on a
federal building
allowed to continue night after night
and so
you know that people are beginning to
understand
what it is that restrains the behavior
of the force
that is supposed to enforce the law
right and that they are
availing themselves of opportunities
that they should not have
because we have effectively carved out a
loophole for one group of people over
here that's going to be
predictably enough exploited by other
people over there
we have to stop that process you
absolutely have to
um have the law now unfortunately
so much here has been politicized that
even um
the you know the phrase that is being
used
is law and order which is in fact a dog
whistle
right law and order is a dog whistle the
proper
non-partisan way to say this is rule of
law yes you have to have the rule of law
and the rule of law can be applied blind
the point is are you attacking a federal
building
that's a crime we have mechanisms we're
not going to provide
a way out because you know we want to
signal that we are sympathetic to
something you're saying the point is
you're not allowed to do that it's
outside the rules
so um yeah we've uh we've set the
the stage for ourselves here and we are
now seeing just how far it goes and
we will see exactly the same thing
censorship-wise
right to the extent that you have these
uh arrogant corporations
that live i don't even want to say on
one side of the ideological spectrum
because i think it's far more political
than anything
but to the extent that they see one set
of things that they will
violate norms like free speech
to address of course those very same
rights that they are generating for
themselves will be
turned on exactly the people that they
would want to protect
so um yeah we've uh
we've we've created a predicament for
ourselves that is going to require
some very careful counter-intuitive
thinking to escape
and brett you you know we're talking
about what
uh the blm riots are particularly
important
why is it that we cannot be consistent
in our thinking
why is it that people who are on that
side
are fully able to condemn trump fully
able to
say this is you know disgusting this is
whatever it may be
but when it comes to their own side they
go well what they're doing is trying to
abolish systemic racism
well you know i uh
i have just a personal rule about this
i don't think that what's going on on
the two sides
is exactly symmetrical right there are
lots of nuances
however my feeling is
if you were condemning blm
and you are not at least trying to
figure out
what part of what happened yesterday is
completely unacceptable and for the same
reasons
you're not really a part of the actual
conversation
you're just a partisan and so if you
were to limit the conversation to
only people who are recognizably
behaving in a non-partisan and
even-handed fashion
the quality of the conversation would
immediately skyrocket
the problem is everybody wants to
amplify
that which leans in their direction and
so what you get is a lot of people
making arguments many of those arguments
may be true but they're making them for
the wrong reason
right they're not legitimate arguments
because what's motivating them is hey
that
that works in my favor rather than
that's actually accurate
so anyway we uh it would be wise
if we figured out how to narrow
the conversation to only those people
who've proven that when a point goes
against whatever their side might be
that they still recognize it
well i don't think that's going to
happen i mean to put it
as pessimistically as i can but what
what i think
maybe it's time to start talking about
is the big tech
incentivization of uh ever spiraling
extremism
uh because we know you know you your
your brilliant podcast that you do with
with heather
uh the dark horse podcast we do this
show to thousands of people we know that
if we
called this this live interview with you
you know
if we wanted to to please a left-wing
audience we would say
fascism in america and if we wanted to
please a right-wing audience
we say patriots succeed in whatever
whatever it would be
or patriots unite patriots unite even
better that'd be great that would be
great
uh so if we if we do either of those
things we
we would have 10 times as many people in
here and 10 times as much passion
and 10 times as many super chats and we
that is the way you you you do things if
you want to get
attention and we've done our very best
to stay away from that we don't always
succeed but we've done our best
but the platforms incentivize that kind
of behavior
and i think the part of the solution
must be surely
in addressing the way that those systems
encourage people to behave because
human beings are very simple we respond
to incentives don't we
well uh we do i think you know the thing
about patriotism the
the sort of cinquanon of the uh
the structure is a willingness to pay a
cost
for something that you believe in and
you know i think
many of us are showing that we do that
naturally i don't find that terribly
surprising i think
patriotism is a real phenomenon and
there are always you know
it's not the most common property but
it's not uncommon to find people who are
willing to sacrifice
um for uh for their nation or for values
that are
are worth fighting for um
but the problem is i mean you know let's
just
i i i it's hard for me to make this
point because
i'm at the center of it but you know
facebook
has now uh tossed the president off
their platform
right that would be
much easier to interpret generously if
they hadn't also
tossed me off their platform right
i mean the problem is facebook has
um displayed a willingness
to evict people who are simply
pointing out the corruption of both
parties
right and so in effect they have come
out
pro-corruption and having done so
now they're throwing the president off
reads in a
in a particular way so i should say for
those who who don't know the story
under a great deal of pressure that was
exerted when i announced on twitter that
i had been thrown off facebook facebook
did reverse course and claimed that it
had been
an error nothing they said about the
issue made any sense but
the point is do you really want facebook
empowered to decide
who is going to get to speak and
if you do what do you think they will do
with that power
one thing they will do is they will go
after people who are non-ideological
and non-partisan right because they are
fiercely partisan
we can't have partisans in charge of who
gets to speak
even when there's somebody doing things
which i think are genuinely troubling
which
i would say is quite true of of trump
especially in
in recent weeks so so what do we do
brett we have these con
we have these companies four or five of
them and they're in charge
and they're the ones get to decide to
to decimate the information what can we
do as a society to take back control
francis brings us logan yeah just
for the hardcore fights take back
control of our tech
all right um so
let's just first notice one of the um
the facts that works in our favor
you've got three kinds of people inside
of all of our institutions you've got
people
who are committed to doing the right
thing in an institution that is fiercely
committed to doing
the expedient thing those people will
not last long they will
be in very short supply you've got
people who are
ruthless and do whatever is in their own
interest
irrespective of what the cost may be
those people will exist at some
level inside of all of our institutions
and then you have people who are caught
in a bind
right these are people who probably are
sympathetic to the idea that the system
isn't working very well that it could be
fixed to advance values that we actually
all
share but they are willing to make
massive
compromises in order to stay employed
in order to advance the narrow interests
of their families etc
and my point would be those people can
actually be liberated to do
the right thing inside of all of these
institutions
and we are foolish to simply read the
fact that they
routinely disappoint us as evidence that
they wouldn't prefer to live in a better
system and be ready to go along with it
if there was some plan
to get there so this was a long-winded
way of saying that strategically
speaking you've got
a lot of people who are capable of
leveling up being good
and collaborating who
can't be seen because their day-to-day
activities
look uh corrupt like everything else
about
about our system and so i would say
we need to start reaching those people
and they need to start reaching across
political ideological lines to their
partners
in competing institutions right now you
can say this
about our political structure for
example in the u.s
there are i think it's a small number
of high quality people in
uh in the congress for example who
could um partner with people across the
aisle
to um to right the ship of state
all right if we do what those who are
taking advantage of the situation
would have us do things will simply get
worse and you know
we will periodically come back to
trigger pod to talk about the uh
you know the new infuriating film that
we've all seen and what its implications
are for the collapse of the west and all
these things but
um but if people who see
the importance of preserving the nation
in the case of the u.s and the west more
generally start behaving like patriots
and contacting those with different
views who share that same
priority there's a lot of good that can
be done so the question is can those
people
what are they paying attention to what
are they reading right
either they're paying attention to
channels like this one
in which case there's hope of reaching
them or
are they paying attention to officially
sanctioned channels that are so fiercely
partisan that
that even though this is the moment for
them to uh
to take control and partner across these
traditional lines
um that they will just miss the call
because they won't know it's out there
and bret what would you say to and this
is a very very left-wing argument that
has been put to me and i can't really
see a way around it that
this is the inevitable result of
capitalism this is what happens when you
have monopolies in charge of
disseminating information
they are ultimately going to act in
their own interests and their own
interest
is in the bottom line is in the profit
margin
i would say a number of things one i'm
increasingly wary of any argument
that is predicated on the term
capitalism if the person delivering the
argument isn't willing to define exactly
what they mean
because in general when i talk to people
on the left about their
uh their their concerns
about capitalism in effect what i
frequently hear
is that they don't like markets
and i know from
several decades of encountering the
problem that markets
are both the source of many of our
greatest
hazards and also our best hope
right markets are very good at solving
certain kinds of problems and so
what we should really be doing is
figuring out how to get markets to
address those problems
rather than demonizing them wholesale
because many of their
products are destructive so
in any case i guess what i would say is
yes
capitalism needs to be
intelligently regulated right and if i
say well regulated people on the right
will hear that as
intensely regulated what i want to see
is it elegantly regulated so that it
actually solves
problems rather than
have market forces turned over to the
faith that if you simply
allow them to run rampant that they will
uh fix everything which
they clearly don't um
brett we've got about another seven
eight minutes of the interview and then
we'll go to our questions from the
audience so guys if you're watching
remember
uh there's a link in the pinned comment
or send us a super chat and we'll pull
them all up at the end and go through
uh the most uh appropriate and
interesting questions
brett what do you see we've seen this i
would say cataclysmic event
yesterday and i know that a lot of
people on the right feel like the
media coverage is disproportionate when
compared to what happened with blm
i i have some sensitivity to that in
terms of the physical
damage in terms of the the cost of the
damage in terms of
number of people who were injured or
killed yes it wasn't quite as bad as six
months of blm burning down central
portland and whatever else
but it happened in one night and it was
the capital during the certification of
an election that is political violence
on a completely different scale
and that's what makes it so important
right so to me there is no doubt
that this is a cataclysmic event with
huge impacts down the line
do you think this will become a sort of
cuban missile crisis moment where we all
wake up to the madness that we've been
living in we see how close we've come to
the brink
and we go we must step back we must find
a sensible way
even if we continue to fight the
so-called cold war
or whatever cultural war we can't fight
it
in a way that leads us to this well it
absolutely
should be that moment i know from
experience
that many things that should be that
moment come and go
and it doesn't happen so the question is
is there
some force that we can exert that can
cause people to
understand what this means and i would
say
you know again i alluded earlier to the
fact that a solution here will have to
be counter-intuitive
right the intuitive thing for people on
all sides is to figure out what this
does to the cause they were advancing
and you know play from there and if we
do that
we will end up on a continuing
escalator of mendacity and essentially
a treadmill of retribution right
it is this retributive instinct that i
think is the greatest danger to us now
many people were enraged by what they
saw yesterday understandably but
you cannot analyze it in isolation
it is the result of many things it is
the result of the corruption of the
system
it is the result of the uh amplifying
influence of social media
and if we're going to dig our way out of
this we are going to have to confront
those processes in ways
that are new and therefore likely to be
easy
to dismiss so
go ahead no no sorry and um one thing
that i really
wanted to talk to you about brett before
we move on
to the super chats and all the rest of
it is i have a lot of friends on the
left i i still consider myself to be on
the left although
i don't think they would but anyway um
and i hear the term fascist
used around trump and there's been lots
of pictures of people with fascist
insignia and
t-shirts and all the rest of it would
you consider
trump to be a fascist and do you consist
consider his actions fascistic
especially those of
last night no
um i consider trump to be
a genuine threat to the established
order i consider him to be the leader
of a cult of personality i consider to
him
him to have severe personal defects that
make it impossible
for him to responsibly wield the power
that he has i would say the
evidence the number of times he has
simply
not taken advantage of a crisis
to institute fascistic reforms that
would have been expected
is many and so what we have is
are there elements of fascism that one
can
find uh over in trump's space
and the movement that surrounds him sure
but you can say the exact
same thing about what's going on over in
dnc
space right the fusion for example
of the state with the corporate is
classic fascism and where that's going
on uh most clearly has to do
with the tech sector and the democratic
party so
um so i guess my point would be look i'm
not even sure
that we're going to see fascism again
right will we see variations on that
theme
we will where will they come from that's
anybody's guess
because you know the whole thing the
whole
apparatus has become corrupted
and the way that that corruption
manifests is uh
simply um it's non-traditional
right we're dealing with a novel
environment and so
fascism has been defined against
historical realities that simply don't
exist anymore so
are there things as frightening as
fascism that we should be afraid of
absolutely but if you know if we're
waiting for it to you know
goose step onto the stage it's not going
to happen well right and i think even
what what happened yesterday
in my assessment is probably more
product of his lack of imagination of
what might happen if you continue to
whip up these
uh frenzies as opposed to him like
deliberately orchestrating uh
mobs to to take over the capital i i
i i think it's probably a false uh
accusation that that often comes from
the left against them
but uh speaking of uh presidents uh what
do you make
of what will happen under his opposite
number because
it looks like uh donald trump has
acknowledged that there's going to be a
peaceful transfer of power
on january the 20th uh what do you think
the biden presidency particularly as i
mentioned with having control over both
chambers of
of congress uh what do you think that's
going to look like and what will america
look like with
president joe biden well unfortunately
it's going to be a disaster that's
essentially guaranteed but it's going to
be
right i should say sorry for for people
who are watching for the first time
not all of our interviews are as upbeat
and cheery as this one
please carry on yes um well
the thing is joe biden is a machine
politician from the heart of the
democratic
national committee so what this
moment is is uh
an old corrupt order reasserting itself
after a period of new corruption and
chaos
and um i don't you know as i said during
the election cycle uh i don't know
which is more troubling certainly the
events
of yesterday um
suggest one very particular hazard that
seems to exist on one side of this in
in a very potent and concentrated form
but in terms of you know it is very
dangerous to have
uh mainstream especially
powerful americans reassured that
normalcy is back and that there's
nothing to worry about
because everything including trump
is a consequence of a system that has
been in crisis
for decades in which rational options
do not exist they are systematically
eliminated
uh for very mundane economic reasons
and that is the problem that has to be
cured because
this was never about trump trump is a
symptom and
if you don't cure the problem worse if
you decide that the problem is cured by
reestablishing the old corrupt order
then you will generate a next version of
trump and it could
easily be far more dangerous
it could be smarter it could be
much more interested in uh
wielding power in an authoritarian
fashion
and uh you know this is this
is the trial run that is supposed to
alert us to that and if we don't take
the hint
um then i guess what's coming is on us
well uh on all of those many happy notes
bret
let's get to some of the questions i'm
starting to hear a bit of an echo
uh i don't know what that's about uh but
uh anton if we could have some of the
the things that people have been saying
uh breit give us a second he's already
sent us through a portion yep so let me
have a look uh
so anton uh says i'm learning more and
more towards
labeling 21 as yeah we're going to have
some of these that i can't read out
brett just because they're
they're more jokey than anything else um
a question for brett says holby hamilton
did anyone learn
anything positive from the evergreen
debacle if so how do we encourage and
replicate positive growth
among the masses well uh we have to
divide that question
did anyone at evergreen learn anything
valuable
i will say the evidence that is coming
out of
the evergreen state college would
suggest that
absolutely nothing was learned if
anything the opposite
somehow the events of evergreen seem to
have reassured people that they were on
exactly
the right track and they have managed to
dismiss
all pushback as somehow evidence that
they were right all along
did anybody in the outside world learn
anything from it well
a good many people clearly did it wasn't
enough
and the fact that the evergreen
pattern has re-emerged all over the
place
continues to be seen at colleges
like bryn mawr and haverford
and has spilled out into
the streets uh would suggest we didn't
learn
enough fast enough but i would say lots
of people
are wide awake and in part the reason
that they are wide awake is that they
saw
a very clear example in the evergreen
story
of what this was and just how broken the
ideology that drove it
was uh and we have a question here from
the wonderfully named jazz giant chicken
who says he's asked a question it's
actually a very good question voters
seem to reach have reached the end
of their tether with the republican
democrat circus now
will 2024 see more independence running
well you know i i don't
know it certainly should but the
mechanisms
that exist to prevent um
people from escaping the duopoly are
subtle powerful and many
and so i think people need to be alert
to the fact that they are being steered
into
a structure that is already controlled
because that structure knows that if
people had a choice
outside of it a rational choice
that that choice would be wildly popular
someone just as a as on the side john
bowring with the tenor says bloody hell
is bret on trigonometry it looks like
we've got two christmases this year
love you all guys well we might not have
any christmases this year the way this
one is going but
uh this is an interesting point and this
is a point that people on the right
often make about this issue brett
uh colin says do you remember when it
was acceptable to storm the senate
during the kavanaugh hearings
the narrative has been decided for you
in other words
that hypocrisy that both you and us
acknowledged
is that that's the central driving force
of the whole
process here isn't it um
yes and i would say in order
that we do not just continue to see a
series of this
in which people point out oh well you
think this is bad what about when it was
the other side and you said nothing you
know we can do an infinite series of
that
yeah what has to happen is we have to
make
a hard break right
we have to
declare a moment at which
behavior like this is not tolerated
and um move forward under a different
set of rules where
a in you know the idea of
um color blindness has been uh
misportrayed and falsely tarnished but
really it is a variation uh on
equal protection under the law the law
must be
blind to who you are and what you
believe and it must be applied equally
and so
we should all be able to subscribe to
that and to the extent that it is
violated by anyone
we ought to be able to say that's not
good for us even if the people
who got the exception we're saying
things that we have some sympathy with
but how is that going to happen brett
we've seen what the democratic party has
represented in the last four years
now that they control every possible
lever of government
how is that going to happen well you
know
you uh correctly detect that i'm not
optimistic
that um having the democrats in full
charge is going to result in this
on the other hand i do believe
that people wake up
and many people who signed up for
some kind of control on the basis
that they thought it spoke to values
that they believed in
are going to realize that in fact they
are putting something much bigger
and more important in danger right you
can't
sacrifice the west over virtue signaling
right it's an absurdity and so anyway
what we can do is we can hope that those
people emerge
and we can recognize them when they do
we can protect them
and to the extent that they don't emerge
we're going to have to force the issue
because um the thing that has just
reasserted its control
is um is hostile to the public
public's interest and is in large
measure
a cause of the problem that we saw boil
over yesterday uh christopher mcmahon
has asked you a question which is brett
any plans for unity 2024
um there are certainly plans
for unity going forward
there are questions about what unity
should be
obviously i think people understood
unity as very much about
an electoral play and there's certainly
room for that going forward but i don't
think it's the only thing
that unity should be about unity
is about the fact that very frequently
no one
speaks for our collective
non-partisan interests and that is
putting us
in jeopardy and therefore i think the
proper role
for unity going forward is to always
give voice
to to the patriotic center
and to provide safe haven for people
from all parts of the political spectrum
who wish to meet in that center so that
we can navigate the way forward i have
to say that the names in in the super
chats are brilliant so someone called
batsa people too says how do we increase
empathy on earth which i thought was
actually an interesting question not
least because
you know we're talking with you as a
sort of social analyst for a political
uh commentator but actually you you know
your your day job
uh and your profession is evolutionary
biology so
is there a way to increase empathy on
earth is it even desirable to do so
yes we've done uh we've done an amazing
job on this front over the course
of thousands of years and only
in you know the last five minutes of
history have we begun to
bungle it so badly the way you increase
empathy is you allow people to see
through your eyes or an enhanced
mechanism would involve the building of
characters and the running them through
scenarios so that you understand it from
their perspective and you know this is
this is so simple we don't even comment
on it most of the time but
how is it that you know a man can know
how a woman sees the world well
you know a really good story written
from a woman's perspective is a
a darn good upgrade so the point is
any mechanism that causes you to see
through the well-drawn eyes of somebody
else
is an enhancement to empathy it is a
very good thing
unfortunately what social media i think
has accidentally done
is the exact opposite where what it does
is it makes people
whose viewpoint is different seem alien
and defective
and it makes people uh who share your
exact
viewpoint seem like the only people who
get it and so it's like an
anti-empathy environment and
um i would say in the short term people
need to violate whatever boundaries
are supposed to keep them from
interacting with others they need to
extend the benefit of the doubt to
people
really hear what they're trying to say
and having gone down this road and
partnered with many others who do this
routinely
i would say it's surprisingly easy and
more important
it's rewarding when you meet people
whose perspective is different
and they articulate it and you hear what
they're saying and you suddenly
understand
why it is that people are so convinced
of something that you didn't initially
see
you'll feel better you'll you'll feel uh
more grounded
so anyway yes plenty of mechanisms and
we should avail ourselves of them and be
afraid of any mechanism that goes in the
other direction
annie asks how do you show people
they're stuck in a particular narrative
and when they automatically assume your
inverted commas far right
for even suggesting a different point
and you could even substitute far right
far left
woke anti-work whatever it is how do you
have conversations in this world that
you've just described
well you know it's a little slow going i
think the problem is that the question
in some sense comes from a perspective
in which
you know you might ask how can you make
sure nobody misunderstands where you're
coming from and you can't
um but what you can do is make progress
so that
over time more and more people
understand that that's not
where you are and it's not what's
motivating you and i would say the
the key tool for this is
to trigger their minds to rise to
consciousness
that by and large human beings hour to
hour
are on autopilot and they only rise to
consciousness when something requires
the attention of the conscious mind
because
it isn't standard and so the way you
get that to happen in conversation is
you raise points that do not
reconcile by some normal scheme
right so uh you know to the extent
that one holds positions that are
not from either slate but are actually a
mixture
that is what you arrive at if you start
from first principles
then pointing out the juxtaposition of
perspectives that don't usually travel
together causes people to have to think
in order to process what you're saying
so
to take just one example people tend
to be either covered
hawks in which case they're enthusiastic
about
masks under all circumstances
they are absolutely believing of medical
wisdom on the topic or they tend to be
coveted skeptics in which case they have
the sense that this isn't a very serious
disease that masks don't work and are
unnecessary
that lockdowns are inherently about
authoritarianism and to the extent that
one says something like
i am a believer that covid is much more
dangerous
than our focus on
death rates would have us believe on the
other
hand i believe we are making a mistake
not
pointing out to people the relative
safety of the outside environment
and that masks are a
socially costly phenomenon and we should
avail ourselves of the opportunity
to take them off when we're in an
environment where the virus doesn't
transmit
right that borrows from both sides and
it doesn't adhere to anybody's script
and it will cause the mind to have to
process it especially
well if you don't mind me saying an even
better and shorter example would be the
way you use the word patriarch because
i it's interesting to me that you you
talk about patriotism quite a lot
because
for a sort of uh leftist professor from
her evergreen or formally of course uh
that is not a word that most people
would associate with you but the way you
frame that word is
essentially about love of country love
of people
uh of your fellow man and woman in your
country and i think
in in a world in which the word patriot
seems to be mostly a preserve of the
right that actually is something that
even when i listen to you pulls me out
of the sort of
you know that that very very binary
thinking that we often have on these
issues
uh and actually speaking about that uh
very issue holly mathner who's
is a big fan of both uh a big supporter
and a big friend of both our show and
yours says is it possible that the
overton window has shifted so far
that those of us who believe in free
speech scientific reality and
individualism
actually are right of center now
well i can't imagine why right of center
would be the right description
knowing holly i'm sure that there is a
uh a good defense of her perspective but
what i would say what i have met is
a good many people whose top priorities
include you know logic
analysis evidence-based reasoning
hypothetical deductive approach a good
many of those people
are effectively sheltering on the center
right because
the left has become hostile to these
things
and i don't think that has anything to
do with where these things natively live
you know of course you know in the not
so distant past
the left would have been you know the
defender of science
against uh people who wanted a religious
exemption
from it um but it is important not
we don't want to mistake science for
that which scientists do science is a
method
right anything that adheres to that
method is science and likewise
we don't want to mistake a set of
beliefs
as resident on some part of the
political spectrum where they happen to
reside at the moment the point is these
are
part of our collective birthright the
the very features that that holly is
pointing to
are so essential to the successes of the
west that i think
the fact is they're their communal
property and
i'm grateful to anybody who will defend
them irrespective of what side of the
political spectrum they're on but
ultimately they have to reside on both
uh an iron shirt has a very very good
question a charming name as well
although the gender equity in
yesterday's capital
deaths i think you can skip that one oh
sorry yep uh
that was absolutely we're trying to give
you the ones that actually are going to
provoke an interesting response from you
there's plenty
because when we normally do live streams
there's a lot of jokes flying around
and stuff like that but when we've got
you on the show we don't want to waste
your time with that
uh so let me it was a great one about
peer review
oh here it is yes so this is from boar
half
uh which is can the academy be improved
by making peer review
financially rewarding
oh boy um you know the academy is
so broken and has you know it it is
suffering from a lethal
number of self-inflicted wounds
um and so you know would it be
better if peer review was financially
rewarding
maybe a little but you know that's far
from the deepest problem with peer
review
so what i would say is we need
if the academy is to survive it needs
a radical rethink there's
no question about this absent to radical
rethink
it will perish from its own absurdities
and paradoxes and the real question
is how do we not go down with that ship
how do we
generate something that
does not have peer reviews defects in
the outside world where we are going to
have to navigate the questions of what
is true
while the academy um you know suffers
its death throes
yeah i it does sound a little bit like
sort of saying would the cancer patient
with stage four
cancer be better off if the room
temperature was one degree higher
there's a there's a bigger problem
going on there right yeah and that's a
subject for another whole conversation i
think because
what's happened in academy is largely
feeding into all the things we've been
talking about
uh and is very sad to see and probably
even sadder for you as someone who was
of that world uh let's let's look at
some paypal as well david says please
keep me anonymous
is it possible that we are witnessing
what we are witnessing
and this is something i've talked about
frequently is uh that what we're
witnessing are symptoms of a declining
civilization
and not just the united states but also
the west in general
um yeah this uh i'll try to make this
succinct but i have argued in a couple
of places
including on a recent dark horse podcast
that the united states
is suffering that actually
born of its corruption is suffering
something that is
the exact analog of the process that
causes a body to
to degrade and fail over time that
in effect what makes a body fail
is that many genes have two or more
properties
and when a property is very good for you
early in life
it tends to be captured
collected and amplified by selection in
spite of its late life downside
because many individuals don't live
to suffer the late life effects and
those who do have already done most of
the reproduction so anyway that's the
biological part of this but
what we have in the us uh
in very potent form is a system
in which when a process let's say an
industrial process
has very good early benefits that is to
say it's wildly profitable
and it comes with late life effects that
are very destructive
like let's say it deranges civilization
by causing people only to hear
viewpoints that reinforce what they
already think
that process by the time we recognize
the hazard
is unstoppable we cannot go in reverse
even when we discover that we are in
mortal jeopardy because the process
puts us in danger so that's the exact
same thing
as the process that causes the body to
fail so in effect
civilization is experiencing what we
call
senescence but i would point out this is
not
a death sentence because we have a
mechanism
for self upgrade and that mechanism for
self-upgrade which
is very well formalized in the american
system but exists across the west
is to effectively
take the values at the core of the
system
the mechanisms that are understood to
function
well and to separate them and
put them into a 2.0 structure in exactly
the same way that a failing human body
produces children that pick up the smart
things that the adult knows the relevant
things
and jettisons the antiquated uh
and wrong things right so we need a
rebirth process
for the west or we will die and leave no
air
and this is from body skies as an
evolution as an evolutionary biologist
what are your thoughts on tennis
mccarran's mckenna stoned eight theory
and to what extent do you think american
politicians
would benefit from guided psycho
psychedelic experiences
experiences as a way to instill empathy
for their
fellow humans this may be reframed as
the joe rogan have you ever smoked dmt
questions um well let's put it this way
um the number of cultures that have
innovated a mechanism for inducing
hallucinations
is indefinitely large
right it's not always um
molecules sometimes it's sweat lodges
and things but
nonetheless we have to understand this
as a positive process which doesn't mean
that simply getting stoned
is good for you but what it does mean is
that many cultures have discovered
a mechanism for breaking through the
normal boundaries of consciousness
and that by architecting that in a
special way
have gotten benefits from it now i would
point out
it's typically the shaman who has the
visions
not the chief right now there are going
to be cases where that's not the case
but
there's some protection in having the
person who is making the calls not be
the person
who is seeing the visions and we may
need some analog whereby we can avail
ourselves
of the insight that comes from
what is essentially a high cognitive
mutation rate
without suffering the hazard of you know
driving while tripping um so yes there
is something down this road do i think
that the uh our leaders need to be
given uh entheogens uh
well a the questioner asked under proper
guidance
were you to have proper guidance that
would be essential for such a thing
um but b it doesn't have to be them
you know and in fact maybe our you know
unfortunately maybe
markets have taken uh the fanciful
narrative generating mechanism that
would play that role for society
and uh harnessed it to a
uninteresting and dangerous economic
plow
but yes we have to resurrect something
so that we can
think outside the box and see
what might be possible without being
limited by you know the normal rules
i couldn't agree with you more bro i
think the only thing that could possibly
make the situation better if gil biden
and donald trump were simultaneously
hallucinating while this was happening
i would take things up a level wouldn't
it but
yeah one of our american uh supporters
colby hamilton
um from texas he he says that he likes
your idea of drafting
a better quality of candidate for
president uh but his concern is how that
works within a system where we're all
human so he says for example you think
mcraven is sent to right which you i
presume doesn't agree with what about
like in 2024
chelsea gabbard dan crenshaw ticket both
very
uh certainly interesting people
i would say have shown themselves to be
quite sensible in many things
uh neither appears to be extremists both
have served or not
both could be described as patriarch
without any sort of
uh question over them what do you make
of his question and
those two in particular well
um how can i put this
i think if you meet a small number of
characteristics
and you come up with a power sharing
arrangement where
things have to be hashed out to the
point of consensus
you've solved almost all of the problem
now in the unity 2020
proposal i did say someone from the
center left and someone from the center
right would need to be paired
in large measure i don't think it's
necessary that that be the case but i do
think it's necessary
in order for the public to understand
that
their interests will definitely be
represented no matter where they are
on the political spectrum so from my
perspective
look all i want is rational people
who are courageous enough to do the
right thing and
not corrupted by uh
finances or anything else if you had
such people
they would make errors there would be
hazards but we'd be so
far ahead of where we are now it would
be a slam dunk winner
so anything that will do the job as far
as
pairing somebody from the center left
and center right in order to neutralize
whatever political considerations would
tend to walk into the room
with the people in question it's nice
but it's really not needed a rational
person
faced with the evidence faced with an
understanding of the full range of
possibilities
will tend to do uh the right thing and
if you had two of them who have to hash
it out
um i'm not i'm not concerned even though
i'm
from what i would say is uh the far
left if you had two people who were
right of center but were
committed to the well-being of the
nation and open to hearing arguments
from all sides about what the best
course forward was i could be very
comfortable with that
uh we have a question from mad hatter
which is
will we ever see another republican
president in the next 20 plus years
and i think this ties into this fact
that a lot of conservatives are
very very worried that donald trump has
done irreparable damage to the party
and its reputation
um yeah i must say i'm so uh
concerned about both of these deeply
corrupt parties that i
i find it hard to get animated over
whether or not we'll see another
republican president what i want to see
is a president who's up to the challenge
right any president from any party who's
seriously up to the challenge would be
great
and who was the last one that we the
united states have had who you describe
as having that
fitting those criteria well um i would
say i have to put a special asterisk
by barack obama's name because i still
cannot explain to myself why he was so
terrible as a president because he does
strike me
he's plenty smart it seemed to me that
his heart was in the right place
um you know he was a marvelous orator
who had the power to inspire people and
yet
at a policy level he was no better and
arguably worse than george bush so
um i don't know why obama fails to test
but he does
i would say the last one who had the
requisite characteristics
was largely understood to be a failure
of a president it was jimmy carter
and the fact is jimmy carter had a very
difficult
set of hazards to deal with the energy
crisis in particular
uh the iran hostage situation and
um you know he i don't know how much
better he might have done
but he would he is not regarded as a
great president because
so little was accomplished however
he's very clearly you know a decent man
and a smart man and patriotic
and so i think in other circumstances he
might have
shined but the
the world since then has been
um has routinely generated
presidential paradoxes i guess i should
also put an asterisk by ronald reagan
who
um i think history
has shown to have been a better
president than many of us thought
he was now in some sense the asterisk in
his case
is about the fact that i'm not really
sure that what he was was president
right he was an inspiring orator who was
effectively hired to do a job and
you know may have gambled in a way that
was unacceptable but worked
out with respect to the soviet union for
example
um but nonetheless uh you know again
it's not that none of the
characteristics were right for ronald
reagan but the sum total wasn't
that's really interesting brad before i
read out another question are you okay
to go for another 10 minutes or
sure yep cool uh i should just say that
while we've been on air uh for people
who are watching you might want to know
that we'll be doing another live
interview
this saturday two days from now with
douglas murray who's a regular on the
show
talking about this this very issue and
uh he wrote a piece
yesterday talking about donald trump's
responsibility
for what had happened and what needs to
happen now and i think
again adding to your very sensible voice
bro i think that's a voice from the
center right or the right
that also needs to be heard on this
issue and uh we're always delighted to
have douglas on the social that that
will be on saturday
same time 7 p.m you can't tell i'm
looking forward to it douglas is a
friend
and uh he's one of a small number of
people whose opinion i take very
seriously
do we tremendous respect for that man
but rocky says and this is a really good
question we've got
i want to acknowledge a bunch of people
who sent us very significant super
chance but
uh jason mcconnell in particular and
others but rocky from canada says
breaking up
is on the rise as an idea and this is
something that worries me tremendously
brett when i see
what i think is deeply irresponsible
talk of secession and breaking up and
all this sort of thing
but it is you can't deny it it's been an
idea look at brexit
in canada uh you know we're talking
about scotland
splitting off in the united kingdom
there are spanish
pieces of that country that want to
break off and have been trying to it
seems to be in the zeitgeist
is that right is that wrong what do you
think oh it's a terrible idea
especially in the us case i mean for one
thing we don't
there is no geographical boundary you
could draw that would
you know allow that separation so the
carnage in question would be unthinkable
um but it's also it's not the solution
to the problem right we have a problem
where we've lost the ability to see the
humanity in each other and we've begun
to imagine that the people on the other
side are just you know
too too dumb to be left on the ship and
it's not true
right are there people too dumb yes on
both sides
um but uh the fact is
understanding what is being said right
it really is true if you
work from first principles and you
attempt to figure out
what is true and what it implies about
policy
you don't end up with a slate that is
blue or red
it's very mixed and
so what that means is if your viewpoint
is blue or red you're missing a big
part of the puzzle right
and so anyway what i would say is
the the idea of splitting
apart is um
it is a cure that is worse than the
disease
by far and the right thing to do is to
start
patching the nation and the west
together on the basis
that actually
[Music]
we have all lost our minds to an extent
and recovering them
is job number one
and we've got a question from manuel uh
which is
what would be a better version of social
media than the one we currently have
what would be a better version well you
know it's a heart it's a little bit
like the um
the question about peer review in the
sense
that uh you know we could dance around
the edges of various things that are
wrong
the censorious instinct is itself a huge
hazard it being wielded by people
who are clearly partisan makes it 10
times worse
so you know for starters what we need is
some kind of 2.0 version of our
constitutional rights
that tells us what we are allowed to do
online
where we are guaranteed the right to do
it uh
and you know lays these things out in a
manner that
would give us some mechanism for redress
of grievances you know it simply can't
be that you log in one morning
and discover you're no longer on the
platform
and that the decision is final and
there's nobody to talk to
that happened to me just that exact
thing and the point is at the very least
right the founders of the us understood
that you had a right to see the evidence
against you to face
your accusers you needed a court right
and in this case
we've uninvented all of that insight
over a largely artificial distinction
between
public and private uh just
i should say and ken dodd's super chat
summarize this he says the right man the
right conversation at the right time
thanks guys so there's a lot of love
for you brett and for uh for the
approach you've taken and
thank you very much for coming uh on the
show uh
but ryan asked a question also from
canada interestingly
uh and this is an interesting question
that i think francis and i as well you
should answer
does everyone agree that none of this is
about biden
which i find an interesting question i
would say i would agree
that this isn't about biden what it is
about is what biden is not
if biden had been a very different
candidate then this would have gone very
differently
but the fact that he he's so he's not
been able to capture anyone's
imagination he's just not donald trump
that seems to be his strongest
uh you know strength uh his biggest
strength
that is probably the thing that has made
this worse what do you think
i think that biden is a representation
of the old order i think
what he is is a skin graft and a
cancerous wound
and the problem is is that people look
at the skin graft it's gone over the
wound everyone's like oh okay
it's fine we can all go about our time
we're back to normal
but the infection is still there and
it's still going to eat away at the leg
unfortunately there's still a lovely
visual metaphor that's what that's the
sort of thing
here yep no i think this is exactly
right and
you know i i don't even think this is
subtle
right now let's leave biden aside he may
be a perfectly
lovely human being at the level of
sitting across the table from him and
talking to him but the
number of places where
a major form of financial corruption
is just outside the range of
where it touches him legally is
vast right i mean we've had an
impeachment
surrounding uh a
business dealings in ukraine of his son
the biden laptop also suggested
influence his
influence was being peddled very
directly to other people and the point
is
i can't as an american say that i
much care that this stuff isn't legally
provable as corruption it's
clear that either hunter biden
was pretending to peddle his influence
right which is one kind of problem much
less serious or that he was actually
peddling influence
and that it was done in a way that you
know kept joe biden's hands
off the immediate consequences but
the real point is hey we have a corrupt
system it's serving
the interests of those who can pay for
play rather than the public
and that is the exact opposite of what
the system is supposed to do
we have a uh super chat from downey jr
i'm not sure if it's robert
if it is we're all a big fan of your
work robert and we want to see iron man
back
in uh the marvel universe uh but anyway
so
he asked do political systems attract
the best people for
the job or are the best people working
in the private sector
living more happy and prosperous lives
great question um a few of the best
people will be found in the system but
by and large the system
actually makes it almost impossible for
them to stick around and i would point
to
tulsi gabbard leaving office
having run into the entire democratic
bulwark and
uh the prevention of all of the things
she would have liked to do
and this isn't the only place that it
happens also i would say
you know many of the people who it would
be wonderful to have in a university
structure
the people who would be you know
scientifically the most capable and the
most likely to make
major breakthroughs end up in the
private sector because
um the hoops they're forced to jump
through in academia
and the low rate of pay just simply
makes it not worth it
so in effect in any place that you have
the best people showing up in a system
that is not there equal it is the result
of what i'm calling patriotism
which is a willingness to sacrifice for
something larger and
in effect if you want the system to work
better then
make sure it rewards the people who
contribute best
you know you want the patriots to do
well frankly and if you did that you'd
see a lot more of them in the places
where they stood to do the most good
uh again as i said lots of love fancat
says thank you so much for such a
balanced well thought out analysis it's
a wonderful interview
uh bret i think we better let you go
because we've had you
for an hour and a half and it's it's
it's a real privilege and a treat for us
and i want to wish you well i hope that
your
commentary and analysis remains a
central part of american life because i
think
it's people like you who actually have a
positive role to play when so few people
are playing a positive role now in the
world so thank you very much for coming
back
uh all the best you and your family and
i hope uh your country recovers from
this because frankly if it doesn't
we're all [ __ ] as well yeah i i
really appreciate that you guys are out
there and uh that you're
holding the line and so anyway um right
back at you
thanks very much brett and thank you for
watching as i mentioned douglas murray
will be on the show on saturday but
we'll be back tomorrow with our usual
live stream
and we'll keep you updated on everything
that's going on thank you for watching
and we'll see you very soon
take care and see you soon guys